[Musique]
et c'est avec vous julien chez dès ce
matin bonjour julien on va reparler de
c2c triple sommets internationaux hier à
bruxelles et au lendemain de ces sommets
bien joe biden menace clairement la
russie de représailles en cas
d'utilisation d'armes chimiques et cela
c'est particulièrement repris par la
presse ce matin effectivement cette
menace en s affiche en une une grande
partie de la presse internationale
regarder cette première page du couarde
yann avec les dirigeants du g7 qui
prennent la pose et cette menace de joe
biden à l'égard de vladimir poutine face
aux craintes d'utilisation d'armes
chimiques par l'armée russe en ukraine
le dirigeant américain n'exclut pas une
réponse de l'otan alors qu'est ce que
cela veut dire concrètement c'est toute
la question à laquelle n'a pas encore
répondu joe biden tout dépendra de la
nature des armes employées dit il le
quotidien britannique rappelle que la
doctrine occidentale privilégiée dans ce
conflit reste la même à savoir soutenir
la guerre en ukraine sans la faire soi
même le journal la croix à lui
s'inquiète d'une possible escalade
militaire et ressort le vieux dicton
latin hérité d'un empire romain si oui
ce pacem para bellum si tu veux la
guerre si tu veux la paix prépare dont
prépare la guerre c'est en filigrane le
message guerrier que lacroix estime lire
dans les dents les résultats de ces
différents sommets internationaux lé
dire l'éditorial rappel avant avant une
prise de parole du pape françois qui
aura lieu tout à l'heure que les racines
de la guerre son jus site dont le coeur
de l'homme mais qu'il existe toujours un
espoir la paix je cite ne viendra ni par
les armes ni par la terreur la presse
qu'il s'intéresse aussi à la situation
sur le terrain et tout particulièrement
à cette ville martyre la ville de
marioupol où sont toujours bloqués cent
mille personnes depuis plusieurs
semaines on sait que la ville est
assiégée et le sort de cette ville
rappelle le triste sort d'une autre
ville ancienne oui je vous renvoie six
ans en arrière cette ville il s'agit
d'alep en syrie sa grande ville pilonnée
par l'armée de bachar el-assad avec
l'appui de la russie et notamment avec
l'appui de cet homme inconnu du grand
public son nom michail mise en scène
c'est un général russe aux commandes des
opérations d'alep à l'époque et de
désormais aux commandes des opérations
de mario paul ont dit qu'il dirige cette
opération
d'une main de fer qui cela lui vaut le
triste surnom d'après le times
britannique
deux bouchers demain au pole il y a deux
images dans cet article que je vous
invite à regarder des images similaires
entre à l'aide d'un côté et mario paul
de l'autre selon le quotidien
britannique la technique de
bombardements ou appelons-la de
pilonnages est la même tout comme
l'objectif à savoir rasé la ville en
dépit de la présence de nombreux civils
sur place d'après l'armée chrétienne 80%
les infrastructures de la ville de
marioupol auraient été détruites
notamment des maternités et un hôpital
pour enfants alors justement on va
s'arrêter sur le sort de ces enfants
vous vouliez nous montrer tout
particulièrement une photo ce matin oui
alors cette photo la voix si c'est
l'histoire d'un cliché qui est devenu
l'une des images fortes de l'horreur de
cette guerre c'est celle d'une
adolescente plongé dans le coma touché
par une balle alors qu'elle fuyait
marioupol avec sa famille le houston
poste retrace l'histoire de ce cliché
pris par un photographe de l'agencé
magnum le nom de cette jeune fille c'est
milena elle a 13 ans elle est en soins
intensifs dans un hôpital de zappos
ridja sa vie n'est plus en danger mais
elle gardera des séquelles de ceux de
sept balles son coût sa langue et ses
vertèbres ont été touchés sa mère
raconte qu'au moment de fuir la ville
leur voiture et est placardisé avec les
mentions enfants à l'intérieur comme on
l'avait vu notamment sur le théâtre de
marioupol mais cela cela n'a pas empêché
les tirs de toucher leur voiture et deux
blessés la jeune fille voilà pour ces
images insoutenables de cette guerre en
ukraine alors on va maintenant parler de
la france et de cette campagne
présidentielle qui approche à grands pas
on est à j - 16 aujourd'hui elle constat
est bien c'est que cette campagne
finalement elle intéresse assez peu les
français les candidats eux aussi sont
pas la peine pour exister et au sein
même des équipes de campagne on commence
à trouver un peu le temps long alors
pour expliquer cette entre guillemets
dont compagne non-campagne pardon il y a
d'abord le contexte entre décembre et
janvier c'était la crise sanitaire qui
dominait l'actualité depuis la mi
février rappelle le figaro c'est la
guerre en ukraine et face à cela c'est
une campagne quasiment impossible à
mener d'après le quotidien de droite qui
parle de code de candidats totalement
désorienté il ya quelques témoignages
fleuri de porte-parole sous couvert
d'anonymat je vous en donne et
quelques-uns c'est désespérant voir si
je suis à mourir certains viennent à
s'impatienter que cela se termine pour
vous donner un peu
l'ambiance au sein des équipes de
campagne mais ce qui inquiète inquiète
globalement au sein de la presse est
bien c'est que cette nos campagnes
n'aboutisse à une abstention face
massive pardon et ne faussent le
résultat final à qui la faute et bien
pour l'opinion c'est la faute des
manuels macron voilà le candidat
président qui a bien sûr des obligations
présidentielles et internationale mais
de là à faire campagne à distance
explique le quotidien sont réellement
rencontrer les français c'est osé et
prat pas franchement fair play comme on
peut le voir ici dans ce dessin de
presse une campagne qui n'intéresse pas
grand monde et cela ce n'est pas de très
bon augure pour les autres élections qui
arrivent à privilégier est effectivement
un petit tour et puis s'en va pour les
députés de la majorité beaucoup avaient
rallié emmanuel macron en 2017 il avait
mis leur carrière dans le privé entre
parenthèses et on apprend dans
l'humanité qu'au moins 80 d'entre eux
est bien ne brigueront pas un nouveau
mandat parlementaire pourquoi parce que
il ya la déception vis-à-vis du projet
m'a craignant oqali pour lequel il
s'était engagé en 2010 a été pour
d'autres et bien c'est la lenteur du
système parlementaire et ses compromis
permanent qui les rebute pour les
remplacer en marche espère refaire le
coup d'il ya cinq ans à savoir attirer
des personnalités à la fois de droite et
de gauche
et on va parler d'un tout autre sujet on
ne peut pas faire l'impasse matin sur
ceux qui l'attaquent lice mauritanie
l'italie qui ne sera pas au mondial au
qatar une nouvelle fois les l'italie ne
sera pas au mondial avec cette défaite 1
0 face à la macédoine du nord en toute
fin de match hier c'était à palerme et
aujourd'hui c'est tout un pays qui se
réveille complètement hagard je suis sûr
qu antoine comprendra très bien l'italie
championne d'europe en titre donc a
perdu son match de barrage synonyme de
non-qualification
éjecté du mondial peut-on lire ici à la
une du de la gazzetta dello sporte à la
une de l'équipe le traumatisme est
d'autant plus grand pour les transalpins
comme je vous le disais puisque c'est la
seconde fois que l'équipe d'italie ne se
qualifie pas pour le mondial alors
qu'elle avait remporté le championnat
d'europe l'été dernier
merci beaucoup je n'y a chez d'un pour
cette revue de presse